[Music]
everyone welcome to eyes on enterprise
where I'll be bringing on Googlers to
talk about how the technology landscapes
are changing how enterprises adapt
modernized and scale my name is
Stephanie Wong developer advocate and
today I have you Fang quo developer
advocate for machine learning on the
show welcome to the show
thanks so much Stephanie I'm really
excited to be here and chat about
machine learning so first off just
thinking about some examples of it do
you have any that you've encountered of
specific ml use cases that have come in
and kind of swept in a company and off
its feet a little bit well the you know
first kind of big examples around these
came from have image recognition type
use cases so you know on the one hand
you have common examples like Google
photos you're really changing how we
think about storing and searching for
pictures and other kinds of recognition
tasks where you can Auto tag images and
then of course medicine is now seeing a
rapid shift in diagnosis in radiology
where they're applying this technology
to find things more accurately more
quickly and more consistently than you
know doctors can't because machines
don't fatigue and they're always you
know consistently they're not gonna be
upset because they were late for work
and stuck in traffic earlier that
morning
yeah and one thing I was thinking about
earlier was machine learning versus AI
think there's a lot of confusion there
about which term is technically accurate
so what's your opinion on that
classically or traditionally AI was
referring to the broad field of just
general artificial intelligence AI and
it was about systems that were
artificial intelligence and anything
really could apply to that back in you
know decades ago in 80s a lot of these
were rule-based systems so there were
things that behaved like an intelligence
you know would at least how back then
folks thought about it but they were
just rule-based systems if statements
and things like that if this happens
then we'll do this and not terribly
complex right but there were lots of
different approaches to doing AI so AI
is kind of the broad umbrella yeah
machine learning then becomes one set of
tool
to try to achieve AI and it's possible
that will ultimately kind of achieve or
do better in AI with some other set of
tools that isn't even machine learning
or maybe evolves from machine learning
and so machine learning is really about
some mixture of statistical inference
and kind of training on some set of data
and creating a model and doing these
predictions yeah that's great I think
they're used a lot of the times
interchangeably but it's great
clarification to have because they
really are quite different in what they
encompass absolutely all right so let's
talk about a typical use case for an
enterprise for a company that's just
looking to get started dip their toes
into machine learning for the first time
what would you describe as the workflow
for them to get started
yeah so you know assuming that they have
some kind of system they're trying to
model some kind of tasks they have in
mind the first consideration then
becomes checking to make sure they have
the data and if not collecting that data
and so for example if they want to
figure out consumer preferences say
they're a retail store and so they'll
collect that data around purchasing
patterns and things like that and many
retailers these days probably have that
data already that's sitting around
somewhere they've got to figure out how
to get their hands on it because it
might be siloed off in different parts
of the organization and their people
might be holding on closely to that and
so getting access to that in a way where
you can aggregate data together is
important and then once you have that
data you can do analysis on it so that
becomes kind of the next piece looking
at what data do you have is it useful
are there signals in it and from there
you can do kind of the traditional
machine learning training piece of it
where you take that data train up a
model and then deploy it to make
predictions but we're not quite done yet
just because you've created a model and
put it in production doesn't mean that
you can now forget about it and just let
it sit there just as you wouldn't leave
production code out on your website or a
system and just say I'm done we don't
need software developers anymore this is
the software has done is you're going to
sit there that's not going to work
and so models need to be updated over
time as well as purchasing patterns
change with the seasons with the years
that information should feedback and
inform updated models right so content
evaluation of model and then as things
change you need to incorporate that into
training exactly so it's kind of in a
lot of ways just like software developer
you may name your model over time so I
want to dive into that a little bit more
because I know that you had a video that
was very popular a couple years ago that
were was on the seven steps to machine
learning and that included gathering
your data data preparation choosing a
model training evaluation and hyper
parameter tuning and then prediction as
well so can you tell me about each of
the steps a little bit in detail who do
you hire for each of those and what are
the trade-offs a little bit more about
that sure so with have these seven steps
so to speak you know there's no real you
know seven steps six steps ten steps you
can break it out however you'd like it
was just really one way to delineate it
and a lot of times different steps can
be collapsed into one you know job role
could be one week's worth of work where
like you gather data and you have do
that day of preparation cleaning and
things like that that might go together
you might end up making a pipeline where
as new data comes in and you know how
you would like to transform it you can
set up a ongoing streaming job where
that data coming in gets transformed and
then deposited in some kind of data
warehouse then looking onwards to things
like training and model development as
well as as you alluded to hyper
parameter tuning this is really the the
meat of it where a lot of people spend a
lot of their kind of mental energy
thinking about modeling in a lot of ways
especially for known use cases and kind
of solved problems that aren't research
bleeding edge situations you can use a
lot of existing state-of-the-art models
and adapt them for your particular data
set customize it and get really pretty
much state-of-the-art results for your
data set so I want to go back to a point
that you mentioned earlier about model
evaluation can you talk about why it's
so important for an organization to
consistently evaluate their model are
there any use cases what that showcased
that it's so crucial or failures that
you've seen yeah so so we can take kind
of a toy example and work through
right the the data that you are
predicting on needs to come from the
same world so to speak that you've
trained the model on so this in
statistical terms means like your
training evaluation tests that all this
data needs to come from the same
distribution essentially and furthermore
that distribution also needs to reflect
the reality of the world right so
there's two pieces to it for example if
let's say we go and we train a model
that can recognize pictures of lawn
furniture
so chairs and you can go and you go in
the studio and you take your your you
know your chair company you make lots of
different kinds of chairs so you're
gonna make a model then maybe you make
it happen people can hold up to their
camera to the chair and be like yes it's
this kind of chair now I can go buy one
for my lawn as well yeah and so you
bring in you set up a big studio and you
bring in all your latest hottest chairs
you know for the next season and you put
it on nice backdrops with good lighting
and you take a bunch of pictures and
videos and do a pulse shoot then you
take that content all those images and
you train it a machine learning model
that can recognize these images this is
great if your task that you're trying to
make is a model that can recognize
pictures of your products in say your
catalog right because those are the same
pictures basically and there will be in
the same situations and lighting all
that but it doesn't really help our
actual use case where they are going to
be in your customers homes with the
backdrop of grass and other you know the
patio and things like that they'll be in
the context of other things so you gotta
catch your data in the same world that
you're gonna be predicting on and
furthermore and this is kind of the
ongoing evaluation piece what happens
when winter comes and that green grass
turns white mm-hmm and your models never
seen snow before it's gonna start having
problems and so this is why you need a
diversity of training data in all sorts
of scenarios that is representative of
how you expect your model to be seeing
these images during prediction time so
hence
constant evaluation and then just as
important to collect data points of
labels that are the prediction that
you're looking for but also examples
where it's not that absolutely yeah so
in this particular scenario it would
mean also having images of these
environments with your chair removed
right so just a normal lawn maybe
there's some leaves on the lawn so of
course the question arises what if the
validation performance of the model is
just isn't up to par yeah I mean poor
model drones can come from all sorts of
factors you know it includes things like
the wrong modeling technique maybe it'll
have enough data on maybe you're
overfitting on that data there's there's
lots of possible causes and this is kind
of where expertise and experience really
become valuable is it's you know easy to
follow the kind of golden path of just
do this and do this and do this and all
work but then when something goes wrong
fixing problems that's where you know
expertise comes through yeah and
overfitting what do you can just
describe that is so overfitting is
essentially a way to describe the fact
that the model has memorized the
training data this is bad because it is
gonna struggle them with real
predictions because all it knows is the
exact training there so in an example
with images it's basically memorized
these pictures and said you know hi
we'll only classify this as a lawn chair
if I see this exact image or these 10
exact images so let's say I have my
problem I've collected the data prepared
it what do I do to set it up and what
tooling exists out there what's the
general developer experience for machine
learning yeah so for developing your own
model there's a lot of libraries out
there today
things like tensorflow being a prominent
one an industry that's really seen a lot
of adoption of course there's things
like scikit-learn which is as I
mentioned earlier it's kind of a machine
learning but not technically deep
learning it's deep learning adjacent but
also a machine learning toolkit and of
course there's also things like Carris
and pi torch and other deep learning
tools that can also be employed to your
model a given data set and then in terms
of a language like r which is more
targeted toward statisticians who have a
lot more experience with that
sort of thing you can also use it for
structured data sometimes language
models will show up there but by and
large the industry has seen this real
shift to using Python as the language of
choice around doing machine learning so
I want to talk about this by problem
type because as you said a lot of
industries have their own styles of data
sets and they need to approach it in the
right way so can you talk about how you
would do that yeah so I think the first
question you have to ask yourself when
you you know want to do some kind of
machine learning a data science task is
is it a descriptive problem is it a
predictive problem or is a prescriptive
problem so I know those are kind of long
words and they all kind of sound similar
so let's go into each of those a little
bit a descriptive problem is really kind
of your traditional classic data
analysis problem a lot of times when
people think they need a machine
learning solution really they're just
asking you know given some data can you
help me find some patterns in it I don't
really know what I'm looking for can you
just describe some interesting things so
dashboarding putting up some nice
visualizations cleaning up the data so
you can do that that is in a lot of ways
a good first step to even doing other
types types of machine learning tasks so
that's descriptive and then there's
predictive which is much of what we
classically think of as machine learning
you know you have your training data
there's something you're trying to
predict right and then you're trying to
model and make these predictions so
that's something where you have inputs
in the real world and then you say you
know i predict today this will you know
be a good outcome or not and things like
that are given a tweet is it a positive
tweet or a negative tweets like that and
then thirdly we have the prescriptive
tasks and these are a little more
uncommon at this point because this is
where you were saying i want to build a
system that will tell me what to do next
and so that has some element of almost
like if we're playing a game of like
chess or something right what does the
next move i should make and this system
should be thinking about what is my my
opponent playing and what options you
have and kind of gaming it out so it's a
little bit of game theory in there
things like that and so this is why it's
a little harder to do in the real world
because such a system would need so many
inputs right you can't just model the
entire known universe and be like ah the
perfect man exactly
alright so I want to talk a little bit
about processing because a lot of
companies are looking towards the cloud
to do training and production is this
the only viable option to really do it
at that scale or is there an opportunity
for hybrid approach when you look at it
from the perspective of your data set if
you have a huge data set and you don't
have any way of really storing it on
Prem and there's more data coming in all
the time there's only one answer right
but in a lot of situations today maybe
you're only interested in doing machine
learning on a certain slice of data on a
certain subset and there it might make
sense to do training locally and then
deploy that to the cloud - you know
alongside all of your other applications
there's a number of different ways to
slice and dice the different workflows
in the cloud you know but it basically
boils down to self-service and managed
services and so a self-serve situation
would be your classic make a VM
configure yourself put whatever you want
on it run your training now maybe you
put it in a kubernetes cluster if you
need more machines things like that and
then on the other hand you have managed
services which are more along the lines
of putting up a Python package or
putting up your code and then having
this managed service take care of the
provisioning and setup and teardown of
these machines after they finished
running your job running your training
job and I'll put that exported model
file in terms of thinking about which
one to do I think the big one that I've
seen come up in terms of why would you
want to serve a machine learning model
locally and that answer typically is
along the lines of response time and
latency so sometimes you have a model
that goes on a mobile device and it
needs to work either more quickly or
work in situations with no connectivity
and so then you would shrink that model
down put it on your phone and embed it
into your application on the other side
of things you why would you keep it on a
local server and your own data center
maybe you need to be close proximity you
need to be close
to wherever you're communicating to
typically that shows up in kind of
financial situations where you need to
make kind of millisecond decisions and
these predictions are only good for the
next slight window of time before the
markets change oh yeah yeah so it makes
me think of stock market and then on the
mobile side IOT use cases absolutely
yeah so one thing I've been curious
about was how long training needs to
take and how many iterations does a team
need to go through before achieving an
optimal model that they can deploy in
production yeah this is kind of the
quintessential question about machine
learning you can train a small model on
a moderate sized data set in seconds low
number of minutes but if you have a big
data set and you have really high you
know requirements of accuracy or
performance
it might take weeks even to train up a
mind like some of these huge research
models that are really pushing the
state-of-the-art they're literally
training on hundreds of GPUs pushing you
know petaflop sub power Wow and doing
this for weeks on end yeah and then at
the end you have a model and it's like
oh I hope that works yes I just burned
all of this computer and time hoping to
get something out of that but yeah it
really comes down to what are you
optimizing for do you how much do care
about those accuracy metrics you know in
a situation where maybe you're making
recommendations on a website you know
you're shopping and it says you know hey
some other products that are similar to
this product you know for them is a
little bit off or looks weird yeah take
care is the real question exactly yeah
but on the other hand in situations like
a self-driving car or a medical
diagnosis like these are literal
life-and-death decisions and so having a
model that is reliable performance and
accurate is way way more important and
the stakes are much higher the
self-driving car news case is another
one where latency matters and so that's
why you are not gonna see cards
signaling it back up to the cloud be
like well should I turn left right you
might run into a wall at that point
exactly so what are our options at
Google to move from dev to prod and have
it work reliably in production at that
scale one of the services we have
is the cloud platforms prediction kind
of sort of managed service and all you
really need to do is take your exported
model say here it is give it a name and
you're basically done it's pretty
magical in that sense because it's an
auto scaling service so you don't have
to worry about provisioning
infrastructure responding to spikes in
demand you know maybe in during the
holidays during weekends things like
that and so it'll automatically scale up
and then automatically scale back down
when traffic dies off and all you have
to do is finish training model and kind
of toss it over the wall in some ways
you know I know it's said a lot that you
don't want to just toss the model over
the wall from your data science team to
kind of your production ization team but
if your model is being deployed in
production by a service and you know the
data scientists can basically just do
that themselves it's like one command
yeah then it kind of changes the game in
terms of where you can spend your time
you can focus on getting good data
getting good training outputs and then
once that's done and you're ready to
push it to production it's not like this
onerous task that you then have to you
know get another team to handle and
coordinate with the modeling team and
things like that yeah I'm seeing that as
a commonality for you know cloud in
general we talked a little bit about
managed services versus custom modeling
and I know we have varying options at
Google as well can you dive into that
yeah I mean it all comes down to your
comfort with kind of building running
and maintaining these systems yourself
and expertise you have in-house as well
as when you think about do you want this
to be kind of an investment in the long
term or is it something where you wanted
to just kind of work and like have it be
good enough manage services things like
auto ml and they're gonna be necessarily
a little bit more constrained because
you can't have them be fully customized
that's the nature by definition of this
comparison I think there's a key point
here for those who don't necessarily
have the right skill sets or they don't
have the time then that's a great option
is to utilize machine learning api's and
then even for those who have experience
with tensorflow and I know tensorflow 2
is out now but we have libraries that
people can leverage instead of
reinventing the wheel and creating a
model for me they get it go
exactly okay so I want to talk about
some of the amazing use cases because I
know you've worked with many companies
in the past so industry use cases in
medical field IOT that are really
utilizing the advancements in machine
learning and some of the Google tooling
two that come to mind is one is the type
of advancements on the medical side
right diabetic retinopathy is kind of
this leading cause of blindness and
Google has made huge strides in
improving the diagnosis of diabetic
rehme retinopathy which has kind of
helps prevent blindness as a result kind
of side effect of diabetes and so that
effort is kind of ongoing and the work
they've done in the publication's you
know for me it was the first time I'd
seen a computer science paper get
published in the in JAMA in the Journal
of the American Medical Association
which is like you know when does
computer science get to publish in the
medical journal so that was really cool
on the other
kind of use case I got to work a little
bit with rainforest connection and there
are nonprofit that kind of helps prevent
illegal logging in the Amazon and they
have these devices called guardians out
in the forest and they're listening
they're listening for the sound of trees
being cut and cut down right because
they're the zoo so then they have all of
this audio data coming in and they need
to process that and they need to pick
out from there and recognize you know oh
they're sound from them then they can
notify law enforcement right and they
can go out and prevent that stuff that's
really cool yeah so and the other cool
thing about it is now they're taking
that data they're saying Wow all this
data and they're realizing what else is
in this data set they're hearing sounds
of animals endangered species yeah and
they can start using that information to
find you know movement patterns of
animals throughout their jungle which is
like just wild yeah okay so we just
covered a lot of surface area and when
it comes to machine learning I mean
companies need to think about having
enough for compute and storage the data
sets the right personnel and then
constantly reevaluate their models as
new data comes in so how can you kind of
digest all of this yeah it's a real
culture shift in terms of making a
company and business data aware and
using kind of data in an intelligent
fashion it's not gonna happen overnight
but I think getting started
later is really important and you know
it's gonna take time but it will really
transform and of how a business can you
know really take advantage of the
information that it already has so with
all that being said what can people do
to get value out of ml right now yeah I
mean it really depends on kind of where
you're at in terms of your experience
and when you already know but you you
can kind of think about it in terms of
do you wanted to have managed services
and api's where you can get started just
understanding and digesting some of
these high-level concepts about machine
learning and bring it in and seeing what
comes out the other side so to speak and
if you already have some familiar with
that then diving into the tools directly
whether you're using tensorflow or
Kerris and just trying it out there's
tons of amazing materials out there
today in terms of tutorials and guides
and workshops and videos another area if
you're looking to like just play around
with ml so to speak from a conceptual
level Google has a set of AI experiments
which are just a ton of fun you can try
them out in your browser also you have
your show AI adventures so I'm
encouraging everyone to check that
series out because he's gonna go a lot
more in detail on some of these topics
overall please check out the blogs the
videos we're gonna have the links to
what he just mentioned in the
description below I want to thank you so
much for being on the show today you
think I learned a ton
thanks so much Stephanie it's been a
blast and also please comment on your
thoughts on the show
what ml projects you're working on the
tools you're using and your thoughts
about what we discussed today thanks
again for checking out ice on enterprise
[Music]
[Music]